it feels like the fighting is really
intensifying in the donbass region and
what is your update on what the
situation is
yes unfortunately there is
fearful fighting ongoing in the east of
the country and unfortunately also
bombardments of cities across the
country
are continued by russian federation also
fighting is ongoing in the northern
eastern part and and southern part of
ukraine
so the situation is not getting easier
on us and that's why for us uh it's
extremely important that there is a
continued
stream of uh military support coming to
ukraine uh because the urgency the
quality and the quantity of the weaponry
that could be provided by our partners
is basically critical for our ability to
withheld this um this attacks
it feels as if much the story of the war
so far has been about ukrainian success
in repelling
forces from kiev in taking back some
territory more recently
are you concerned that as russia focuses
on the east of the country that
narrative might be changing
you know
it's not about the narrative we don't
have
many options on the table
we have to survive in this war that when
the aggressor has come to erase us from
the map of the world and we want to live
and want to build our country and want
to preserve our nation so uh therefore
we have to win um and that might require
all resolve that might require all our
ability to fight uh and and the lots
unfortunately it already takes a lot a
lot of of ukrainian best ukrainians
lives um from the military and also from
the civilians um so therefore um it's
not about the narrative we have to push
it uh push it against russian federation
and yes unfortunately at this particular
moment when russia has gathered all its
military capacity in the in the east of
the country uh we are losing some of the
territories and um and and they are um
staying in the at this particular moment
in the the hands of occupiers but we
hope there will be a moment
and the possibility for us to to get
those territories and people back
you're talking about the need for more
weapons from all supplies from the west
what is the situation with suppliers
there have been some reports about
people even running out of ammunition
well the supplies are coming in and we
are extremely grateful for those nations
that are making this effort and that are
um
also showing example to those who have
been hesitating or who have been much
slower
on this track but at this particular
moment definitely this is still not
enough for us to have the
uh enough artillery capability enough
multiple uh launch rocket systems
capability to fight back all that uh all
those rockets and artillery and tanks
that that are um coming from russian
federation they are not counting the
they are not counting the munitions they
they have just uh more than enough while
sometimes unfortunately in some of the
areas the ratio of our weaponry is one
to ten with the russians
oh yeah that really is a pretty stark um
example there that that ratio that
you've just given to us there's been a
bit of criticism from some about some
european countries but being too slow
to show support for ukraine do you feel
that that's changed this week
with the news from the eu that you've
been given membership candidate status
and also of course the visit
to ukraine from the leaders of germany
france and italy
i think it was very important visit um
of those of those leaders of the eu and
uh very important that they have finally
made up their minds uh to support the
candidacy of ukraine uh to join the the
european union however i would um also
like to to underline that doesn't that
uh that decision uh which i think is um
is totally
you know right thing to do at this
particular moment for ukrainian people
and for ukrainian state um should not
dismiss the other needs of
of our country and those are
we call it i call it as a major
humanitarian aid for ukraine in terms of
actually getting weaponry unfortunately
we are not getting enough from those uh
particular states and um well like
germany has been
giving smaller weaponry and we
understand that that was already a big
change in their policy
but so far heavy weaponry does not come
really from from from that country and i
think it's a big mistake of germany
trying to kind of postpone those
decisions
uh so far but i hope that after you know
chancellor schwartz and after the the
other leaders have actually seen the
uh ruins and destruction that russians
have uh have brought
on our land near near cave uh with their
own eyes maybe that could change their
actually personal um
readiness to take the decisions on
additional weaponry for us to protect
because we are protecting ourselves
and how does it contrast with the uk uh
boris johnson of course made his visit
second visit to kiev this week
you know we uh extremely appreciate um
his visits and his real
uh very clear stance on the need to
support uh ukraine by the free
world by free countries and we are uh we
are grateful for his leadership i think
to an extent maybe his visit has a kind
of balance the need to talk and
prioritize the security and and the
military assistance at this particular
moment in comparison to what the other
leaders saw the day before have been uh
talking about so we would like others to
to also um
follow the path and follow the example
of of britain in terms of britain and
the us uh in terms of helping us with
the with the weaponry
and just finally you know i've been
talking to you as a politician so far
and i'd like to kind of finish by
talking to you as a mother and
i've you know read some of your
interviews previously and i think you're
a mum of teenagers
and i just wonder how it is
for you um you know having
children in the middle of a war
how do you parent how do you explain to
them what is going on and how do you
make them feel reassured
uh thank you for asking i think this is
probably the the most challenging part
of our jobs today so to say
to to ensure that um that they are
getting that support that
and and that we are there for them uh
because we we cannot unfortunately spend
enough time with our kids um at all at
this particular moment when you are
preoccupied with serving the country and
you actually sometimes you have to
actually choose the
the responsibility um in front of the
country uh as a first and major option
and then and then going um going and
helping um even psychologically or you
know emotionally helping your children
but we are trying to to do that all of
us who are moms uh in uh who are in the
parliament or in the governmental
positions
uh it's tough they are
i think uh the generation of our kids
that's my feeling from what my my
daughters are telling me
uh one is 16 another is 19. um and
this is the generation that will not
forgive russians um in
the the the destruction the death the
uh the the pain that they have brought
on our land and it's not because we are
teaching uh them this it's because what
they are watching and how they are
watching uh the situation developing and
how they are becoming
um
you know very
full
they are full of pain uh they are full
of desire to engage and to help so they
are volunteering for for different
things and
and and trying to do their their least
at least something that they can do uh
their most uh to to to help also the
armed forces and that's um i think shows
also the the incredible unity of the of
the society because the society is
comprised of those little tiny bits and
little human stories
uh that they have and
you know i hope they can come back to 2k
if they are not in cave in this
particular moment they really want to go
to to come back home uh but uh so far we
do not feel that it is safe enough for
them to be to be home
that's her really i hope that situation
changes for you soon and that you know
keith is safe enough for your daughters
to return
um thank you so much for talking to us
uh this week
thank you